we have come this far together we offer
a good life because we're the party of
working people as the most expensive
council properties for vacant we're
going to require counsel to sell them on
just like with health just like with
their tax cuts of their promises they
have absolutely no idea where a penny of
this money is coming from well I say if
the best-looking service can come up
with is a hall reheated version of one
of Margaret Thatcher's 90 days and 80s
ideas i think it just tells you all you
need to know we've got two very separate
parties jostling for the votes of the
swing voters that's given us the kind of
politics that we have now a politics
that select so many disappointed and
even depressed you may or may not know
this region bookmaker asking people what
they love most about version and the top
arson was the countryside in meeting the
Queen Anne fish and chips I worked over
25 years um you don't look old enough
thank you but how long have you work
here will two years how is it good
that's for the right arm prolly oh no
yeah